so my question is how can a 22 year old
make himself useful
or stand out to a business person that
can perhaps take a risk to
pull me along and teach me what are the
skills and things
you would need to see in a candidate to
even consider teaching him
he's having a hard time finding a mentor
what do you say a 22 year old that's got
so much ambition barbara mentors are
overrated
really sure who showed you the way was
it one mentor that pointed left or right
and you found your way i doubt it
no the life of hard knocks pushed me all
over the place absolutely so what he's
looking to is someone else for an
answer bad idea all your answers have to
do with yourself
what you experience what you expose
yourself to how much you play in the
traffic
what you reject what you accept you have
to find your own path in life
this guy is looking for someone else
with the answer like i'll follow you no
we're called individuals for a reason
everybody's an individual he's got to
find his own gig
you get help from friends you need help
from uh more senior people in your field
but in the end you have to find your own
way i really believe that
i think the kid's off to a good start
though he sounds like he's got his stuff
together i like the international aspect
oh he doesn't believe he's got a stuff
together well
because he's looking for the answer
somewhere else if he tries any one of
these businesses he's got multiple
opportunities
go make something happen he'll learn
pretty quickly how damn hard that is
yeah of course i'm okay with that answer
maybe i won't throw you out the window
on shark tank all of our good
entrepreneurs never really listen to us
they listen but they don't follow our
advice
they find their own advice and that's
the mark of saying well they listen when
we won't give them a deal because their
valuations are too high
you